it's a high-stakes political standoff on
one side Republican leader Kevin
McCarthy in most of his party on the
other a Cadre of strong-willed
Republican rebels in six ballots over
two days McCarthy's mainstream
Republicans have failed to muster the
votes to elect him as Speaker of the U.S
House of Representatives a Speaker has
not been elected it was a scene of
Republican disarray a block of 19 then
20 then 21 mostly members of the freedom
caucus repeatedly stopped the party
leader from reaching the necessary 218
vote threshold McCarthy began the second
day of voting with optimism
but the Republican Rebels want to
dramatically limit the size of the
federal government and overhaul the
Congressional rules to do that and a
series of concessions failed to satisfy
them after hours of deadlocked votes
they took a three-hour break for equally
fruitless negotiations will the house be
in order then quickly adjourned for a
second day without a speaker
Democrats watch the slow paced collision
with Glee One bearing an armload of
popcorn the contrast between house
Democrats on the chaos and confusion
taking place on the other side of the
aisle could not be more clear
Democrat Hakeem Jeffries topped every
vote but fell short of the majority
needed to win
without a speaker the house can't pass
laws make committee assignments or even
swear in its new members leaving the
United States without a functioning
House of Representatives
one Democrat in particular lamented the
Congressional chaos it's embarrassing
for the country
I mean literally and I I'm making a part
of this reality
that you know to be able to have a
Congress that can't function is just
embarrassing we're the greatest nation
in the world how can that be
as Republicans battled it out on the
house floor President Joe Biden joined
Republican Senate leader Mitch McConnell
at a bridge connecting Kentucky in Ohio
funded by a bipartisan infrastructure
law showing that even divided government
can function when both sides cooperate
John hendren Al Jazeera Capitol Hill